how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel to cosmic
wonder where of course we talk about all
things relating to Marvel and today
we're talking about the trailer for
venom 2 now if you caught a video or two
that I did about the venom 2 trailer a
couple of days ago we know that the
venom 2 trailer is almost here and this
is according to Deadline and according
to a twitter account who has leaked
numerous things about trailers coming
out and has been right before and just a
few days ago we found out that the venom
2 trailer is in the localization process
which means it's right around the corner
and that also means that it's most
likely been distributed to some outlets
and that's usually for purposes like
translation and it appears that somebody
saw the Russian version of the venom 2
trailer and has described and translated
what they saw and we even have some
footage of what is apparently going to
be the final scene of the venom 2
trailer now keep in mind this isn't 100%
confirmed to be what the trailer is
going to be however given the fact that
the venom 2 trailer is in the
localization process and is about to be
released there's a high probability that
it is true and hopefully we'll be
finding out this week so let's dive
right into it if you're new don't forget
to subscribe to stay up to date on all
Marvel content and to enter my giveaway
for a chance to win a Xbox one or ps4
I'm picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers the trailer
begins with the logo of Marvel and Sony
the next frame is a view of San
Francisco while somebody's talking and
says a new hero protects the city next
we see a scene with children dressed in
Halloween costumes in a large house a
man opens the door and gives candy to
the children this man turns out to be
Cletus Kasady
wearing a mask Cletus VIN says sweet or
foul - which he then takes off the mask
and you can see that it's half of
Cassidy's face and half of Carnage's red
face with its open mouth and sharp teeth
then he says I think it will be
disgusting
he then laughs next we see scenes with
the police chasing Cletus who is chasing
Brock and his red car then a detective
ass Brock where Cletus is in the next
scene Eddie sees a newspaper about an
orphanage being set on fire and then
cletus's voiceover says taking the lives
of others as pure art and this was
actually confirmed by a photo that Tom
Hardy posted on his Instagram in the
next scene we see Eddie walking around
the neighborhood of San Francisco and
saying
venom he's going to finish this next we
see a scene where Brock transforms into
venom in the air who tries to climb to
the church where Cletus is located then
the frame darkens and cletus's voiceover
says my goal is greater than death
the final scene ends with the police
officer shooting Cletus but he catches
the bullet with his symbiotic tentacle
he then distorts into something else
most definitely carnage witnessing this
the police officer begins to scream just
like the first venom movies trailer and
this is supposedly the description for
the first teaser trailer for venom 2 and
it shows carnage and this description
for the venom 2 teaser trailer is most
likely true and I'll even show you
footage many of the scenes that are
described here have actually already
been shown to us we have definitely seen
leaked photos of the cathedral and we've
even seen leaked photos and leaked
videos of Woody Harrelson playing Cletus
Kasady getting shot by a police officer
after driving around in the red car that
is mentioned in this description but we
see that something catches the bullet
and we even see a prop for a red
symbiotic arm no doubt carnage
[Music]
so this is apparently the final scene
that we're going to see in the venom 2
teaser trailer and this is great news
because will actually see carnage in the
teaser trailer which is something that a
lot of us were worried about and for
those of you who were worried that
carnage was going to be toned down in a
pg-13 matter and not be the true carnage
it sounds like he's going to be eating
some children in this movie I imagine
it's going to be something like when
venom bites the heads off of people in
venom one but nonetheless sticking true
to carnage as a character so let me know
what you think about this trailer
description would you be excited to see
this again according to a couple of
reports we should be seeing the trailer
very soon this week so be sure to LIKE
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to
venom 2 and of course Marvel you can
follow me on Twitter for live updates
and as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof